foreign
I'm chair of the Ramsgate Coastal
Community team and one of the members of
the House partnership board my name is
John Walker and I'm the chairman of the
Ramsgate society which is the Civic
Society for a town of Ramsgate I am
Louisa Bobby I am the program manager
for the Ramsgate Heritage action Zone
[Music]
the Ramsgate Heritage action Zone has
been doing a variety of projects that
essentially have been doing a body of
foundational research and what is unique
and special about Ramsgate effectively
it was taking the programs at historic
England already ran and bundling them up
and applying them to particular areas I
think the Heritage action Zone has
really helped local people to better
understand the Heritage that they've got
in Ramsgate and its value it's fairly to
the local economy
[Music]
foreign
pieces of work that was done during the
Heritage action Zone
was the survey of the polymite that's
Victorian artificial Rock and Ramsgate
has a lot of it and we worked with
various experts to
um conserve and repair sectors of the
polymite that were at risk so we now
know the condition of the rock we know
how to repair it and it actually looks
magnificent at the moment in the song as
you go around to see from the Kent steps
public realm project was part of the
historic England schools program so they
their involvement came about because of
the has that project is all about
working with teachers and schools in
Ramsgate to help them understand how you
can run a heritage project and then the
children
designed tiles to tile the Kent steps
inspired by puging's designs and that
that was joyous to walk into a school
and find a hundred kids avidly
researching and preparing work which
they then presented to their parents and
their grandparents and their siblings so
we had that sort of ripple effect the
conservation area appraisal which was
led by historic England
is a fantastic piece of work actually
and it looked at Ramsgate and he divided
it into several what they called
character zones I think there were about
13 or 14. we've been very engaged with
the community who kind of helped Pace
the streets to look at understand review
the their local areas and spaces this is
really where the community have kind of
helped to develop policy so when our
planning team our reviewing planning
applications they can refer to the
conservation area to help steer
decisions it's a kind of red thread that
goes through all the other
projects you know
the word that starking have done over
the last five years has really helped to
sort of prepare the ground for
delivering future projects all the
research
and
Technical expertise actually really
helps and supports people writing
funding bids we were able to secure
High Street funding a small amount of
funding which will actually do something
to improve The Pedestrian access between
the seafront and the town the Heritage
action zone for the High Street which
will
offer grants for improvement to some of
the facades we've now got a town
investment plan which has been invested
in by the district council and we were
able to draw a lot of the Heritage
action Zone research and the
conservationary appraisal to support the
application for the leveling up fund
which was successful and I think that
evidence helped enormously I suspect we
wouldn't have had that success had we
not already had Heritage actions and
status and being able to demonstrate
to the world at launched that Ramsgate
is actually quite an interesting place
and it could be even more interesting
with a little bit of help we're only
just beginning to
an awful lot more
for us to to find and to enjoy
[Music]